ALL THIS.
>> John: A LOT TO BE PROUD IN
THE PEACH STATE TODAY.
>> Sandra: CONGRATS.
>> SLAP ON THE FACE.
WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF A CRISIS.
WE SEE IT EVERY DAY.
BIDEN WAS NOT COMING TO SEE THE
REALITY OF THE BORDER.
HE WAS COMING TO SEE A
SANITIZED, A CLEAN EL PASO.
WHAT WAS THE PRICE THEY PROMISED
THEM TO BE ABLE TO CLEAN THIS UP
AND MAKE BIDEN LOOK GOOD?
>> Sandra: IN EL PASO, TEXAS,
THAT WAS IN EL PASO, TEXAS,
RESIDENT FURIOUS AT PRESIDENT
BIDEN AFTER HIS TOUR OF THE
BORDER TOWN ON SUNDAY.
LOCALS SAYING THE PRESIDENT DID
NOT SEE THE FULL EXTENT OF THE
CRISIS THERE, MANY MIGRANT CAMPS
WERE TORN DOWN BEFORE HE
ARRIVED.
AND JOINING US NOW IS PRESIDENT
AND CEO OF THE UNITED STATES
HISPANIC BUSINESS COUNCIL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
BACK ON THE PROGRAM.
OUR VIEWERS REALLY APPRECIATED
THE LAST TIME YOU JOINED US.
YOU ARE INCREDIBLY PASSIONATE
ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING THERE,
YOU PLACED A LOT OF URGENCY ON
THAT, SIR.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THE
PRESIDENT’S VISIT, FIRST OF ALL.
IS THIS GOING TO HELP ANYTHING?
>> YOU KNOW, I HAVE TO SAY THAT
I’VE BEEN CRITICAL OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION’S HANDLING OF
THAT CRISIS AND AFTER MONTHS OF
MYSELF AND OTHERS CALLING FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO COME DOWN TO
THE BORDER AND VISIT THE
AMERICANS WHO ARE SUFFERING
THROUGH THIS CRISIS HE FINALLY
CAME, SO CREDIT WHERE CREDIT IS
DUE, BUT HONESTLY, A THREE-HOUR
SCRIPTED SANITIZED VISIT, THAT’S
NOT A SOLUTION.
THAT’S A PHOTO OP.
AND WE ARE CALLING FOR A LOT
MORE THAN THIS, YOU KNOW.
HE -- HE -- I UNDERSTAND THAT
JOE BIDEN DID NOT CREATE THIS
PROBLEM, IT’S NOT HIS FAULT.
BUT IT IS HIS RESPONSIBILITY.
>> Sandra: REALLY INTERESTING.
THIS IS THE WHITE HOUSE
DESCRIPTION OF THE PRESIDENT’S
NEW BORDER POLICIES IMPOSING NEW
CONSEQUENCES FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
ATTEMPT TO ENTER UNLAWFULLY,
EXPANDING LEGAL PATHWAYS FOR
SAFE, ORDERLY AND HUMAN
MIGRATION.
THEY ALSO SAY THE SURGE --
SECURING SURGE RESOURCES,
DISRUPT CRIMINAL SMUGGLING
NETWORKS AND SUPPORTING BORDER
COMMUNITIES.
WILL ANY OF THIS HELP?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK IT MAY
HELP.
POLICY IS ONE THING, ENFORCEMENT
IS ANOTHER.
YOU KNOW, THIS NOTION OF SENDING
30,000 MIGRANTS BACK TO MEXICO
IS A DROP IN THE BUCKET.
IT WILL HELP AND RIGHT NOW WE’LL
TAKE ANY HELP WE CAN GET.
BUT IT’S A DROP IN THE BUCKET
COMPARED TO THE 1.5 MILLION WHO
ARE ALREADY HERE AWAITING
PROCESSING.
IN ADDITION TO THAT, WE HAVE
600,000 PEOPLE CLAIMING ASYLUM.
THAT PROCESS ALONE IS ESTIMATED
TO TAKE UP TO FOUR YEARS TO
CLEAN UP.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO WITH
THESE PEOPLE IN THE MEANTIME?
AND AT THE SAME TIME THAT THIS
IS HAPPENING, OUR FARMERS ARE
SUFFERING.
LAST YEAR WE LOST 10 MILLION
TONS OF CROPS THAT WENT
UNHARVESTED BECAUSE WE COULDN’T
GET PEOPLE TO HARVEST THOSE
CROPS FOR US.
SO WE NEED THE PRESIDENT’S
ATTENTION.
WE NEED SOME THOUGHTFUL
RESOLUTION TO THIS, SOMETHING
THAT IS SUSTAINABLE, THAT WILL
HELP THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY.
>> Sandra: THIS IS SENATOR JAMES
LANGEFORD ON WHAT HE SAYS THE
PRESIDENT DID NOT DO WITH THIS
BORDER VISIT.
>> HE DIDN’T MEET WITH THE
BORDER PATROL UNION OR THE LAND
OWNERS OF THE AREA, DID NOT MEET
WITH MIGRANTS.
THIS WAS A STAGED EVENT HE
BROUGHT IN ON SUNDAY TO SAY
LOOK, I WENT, BUT HE’S NOT GOING
TO TRY TO SAY WHAT NEEDS TO BE
FIXED.
>> Sandra: ECHOING THE COMMENTS
WE HEARD FROM YOU JUST NOW.
YOU’VE REACHED OUT TO THE WHITE
HOUSE.
ARE YOU IN COMMUNICATION WITH
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS TEAM AT
ALL ABOUT THESE ISSUES?
>> WE ARE TO SOME EXTENT.
BUT THE REALITY OF IT IS, YOU
KNOW, THEY WANT TO LISTEN TO THE
PEOPLE THEY WANT TO LISTEN TO.
AND LISTEN, I GET IT.
JOE BIDEN HAS THE TOUGHEST JOB
IN THE WORLD.
BUT LET’S NOT FORGET.
HE ASKED FOR THIS JOB.
WE GAVE HIM THE JOB AND NOW IT’S
TIME FOR HIM TO DO THE JOB.
THIS IS A DIFFICULT VERY, YOU
KNOW, IT’S GOING TO TAKE SOME
THOUGHT, IT’S GOING TO TAKE SOME
LEADERSHIP, HE’S GOING TO HAVE
TO REACH ACROSS THE AISLE.
NOT A SINGLE REPUBLICAN WAS
INVITED TO THAT VISIT.
WHERE WERE OUR TWO SENATORS IN
TEXAS, WHERE WERE THE TEXAS
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
WE NEED A LEADER THAT
UNDERSTANDS THE ISSUE, THAT’S
TALKING TO THE AMERICANS ON THE
BORDER, THE FARMERS, THE
DOCTORS, THE NURSES, THE POLICE
OFFICERS, THE TEACHERS, THE
AMERICANS THAT ARE SUFFERING
THROUGH THIS CRISIS.
THEY WILL BEST INFORM HIS
STRATEGY FOR HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD, NOT HIS INSULATED IVY
LEAGUE-EDUCATED CIRCLE OF SIX.
HE NEEDS TO GET BEYOND THAT AND
TALK TO REAL AMERICANS HOW WE
MOVE FORWARD HERE.
>> Sandra: JAVIER, I ONLY HAVE A
COUPLE SECONDS LEFT, AND PEOPLE
ARE LISTENING, AND BY THE WAY,
THE LAST TIME YOU JOINED US WE
DIDN’T ASK BUT YOU VOTED FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND YOU PUT HIM
IN OFFICE AND ALSO SAID AT THE
END OF THE LAST INTERVIEW WE HAD
WITH YOU THAT DEMOCRATS ARE
GOING TO MAKE A REPUBLICAN OUT
OF YOU OVER THIS BORDER CRISIS.
HAS THERE BEEN ANY CHANGE THERE?
DO YOU --
>> SADLY THERE HAS NOT.
I’M WAITING FOR JOE BIDEN TO
STEP OUT OF THE INNER CIRCLE, TO
STEP OUT OF THE BELTWAY AND DEAL
WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, HEAR
FROM US, HEAR FROM REPUBLICANS
THAT ARE ON THE BORDER THAT ARE
SUFFERING THROUGH THIS.  IT CAN
BE DONE, THIS IS HIS MOMENT.
HE CAN ILLUSTRATE HE’S THE
LEADER HE PROMISED HE WAS GOING
TO BE.
>> Sandra: HOPEFULLY HE REACHES